merci de votre présence pour ceux qui
sont là physiquement et bienvenue à ceux
qui sont en visioconférence plaisir cet
après-midi accompagnée de françoise
gatel monsieur mathieu darnaud monsieur
alain milon et messieurs daniel guéret
de vous accueillir pour cette conférence
de presse dont l'objet est le texte 4d
qui vient devant le la science publique
du sénat mercredi prochain qui a fait
l'objet d'une réunion de commission
hier mais qui sont séance publique
mercredi prochain pour une bonne partie
du mois de juillet ce texte que nous
attendions issus du gouvernement dont on
nous avait indiqué d'ailleurs qu'il
porterait en lui même une fortes
ambitions décentralisatrices il n'était
pas annoncée comme étant révolutionnaire
mais en tous les cas comme portant une
véritable ambition est bien nous le
prenons avec de la déception car à la
lecture de ce texte ne faisait pas
apparu que cette ambition là soit
vraiment confirmé dans les articles qui
sont soumis à la sagacité des
parlementaires des sénateurs en
particulier nous le regrettons parce que
le scénar en matière de collectivités
locales dont nous sommes chacun sait ici
c'est pas une redite sommes les
représentants privilégié avait lui-même
beaucoup travaillé avec 50 propositions
importantes que les collègues
rapporteurs ont seulement évoqueront et
puis trois textes de nature législative
ou constitutionnel qui nous permettait
de d'avancé bien je ne veux pas aller
plus loin mais les rapporteurs ont
travaillé ont fait des propositions il
ya désormais un texte de la commission
ou des commissions puisque je rappelle
que sur ce texte
si la commission des lois est saisie
elle a délégué une partie des textes à
aux collègues des autres commissions
monsieur alain milon pour le compte des
affaires sociales
j'ai daniel guéret pour le compte de la
délégation de la commission
développement durable pardon et madame
dominique estrosi sassone que je dois
d'ailleurs excusé cet après midi je le
fais en dû le faire plus tôt pour le
compte des affaires économiques
donc je vais dans laisser la parole je
vous propose de laisser la parole à
madame gatel et monsieur d'arnaud pour
une petite dizaine de minutes
et puis nos autres collègues pour cinq
minutes et privilégier si l'on est
d'accord évidemment les changes et les
questions avec les rapporteurs merci de
votre attention madame gatel merci
beaucoup monsieur le président mes chers
collègues bonjour à tous dont nous
échangions tout à l'heure sur le titre
sur l'objet de notre rang qu'on cale des
3ds
en tout cas nous ne vous dirons qu'elle
est notre ambition
on peut dire que ce texte il se
caractérise par une extrême timidité
tout en ayant le mérite il faut le
reconnaître et nous devons sans aucun
doute à la ministre de la cohésion des
territoires d'être un fils aussi ténu
soit-il tendu pour que sans doute la
sagesse du sénat s'exprime de manière
pleine et entière
le conseil d'état a lui même dans son
expression dit clairement que ce texte
était un peu on va dire un peu trop
léger dans certains domaines annoncées
et notamment le fameux 4e dé kitty celui
de la dea complexification qui en soi
est déjà un mot un peu compliqué et il
lui a préféré le mot de simplification
est il là vous le savez largement
encouragé l'état avoir plus de plus
d'ambition
donc ce texte est fort timide et il est
aussi comment dire
il ya pas de mépris dans mon propos une
sorte par moments d'inventaire à la
prévert parce qu'on y trouve beaucoup de
dispositions qui ne relève pas forcément
d'une ambition de décentralisation mais
qui ont certainement leur leurs pertes
et nantes
en tout cas le sénat a avancé d'une
manière très claire je dirais plutôt
consensuel ne réserve aucune surprise au
gouvernement puisque le président buffel
l'a rappelé en janvier dernier le
président du sénat a lancé un groupe de
réflexion très oecuméniques parce que il
regroupait l'ensemble des groupes
politiques pour élaborer des
propositions qui sont au nombre de 50
qui ont été présentés en juillet dernier
présentait également au gouvernement et
qui ont recueilli l'assentiment des
associations d'élus locaux qui sont en
attente de ce qui est l'ambition du
sénat c'est celle de la lettre e qui est
l'efficacité de l'action publique et un
texte le président l'a dit qui est
attendu depuis depuis fort longtemps
nous nous sommes attaché à donner un peu
de souffle peut-être beaucoup même je
l'espère à ce texte qui je le rappelle
s'inscrit dans l'annoncé faite par le
président de la république de répondre
aux commandes heroes propos qui l'a
fortement entendu au moment du grand
débat et a également aux conséquences
aux effets que nous avons pu constater
pendant la crise sanitaire
ce qui renforce notre obligation
d'ambition alors le premier point c'est
la différenciation c'est à dire c'est
affirmer la diversité des territoires et
la nécessité dans une république une et
indivisible de permettre d'adapter des
dispositions nationales à des réalités
locales dans un seul objectif d'ambition
encourager la différenciation ça n'est
nullement fracturé le principe d'égalité
mais bien au contraire et le conseil
d'état le dit lui même que l'objectif
d'égalité sous tend
un principe de différenciation puisque
pour que jusqu'aux derniers kilomètres
jusqu'au dernier citoyens l'égalité des
droits soit une réalité
il faut savoir adopter les réponses donc
dans le texte du gouvernement il y avait
une reprise on va dire un copier coller
de dispositions constitutionnelles nous
nous en avons accru à porter en
affirmant dans ce texte que la
différenciation doit être un objectif
qui doit être prise en compte dans les
dispositifs législatifs il nous avons
même inscrit au proposé une procédure
adopte donc nous affirmons que la
différenciation doit être non seulement
pris en compte dans tous les textes
législatifs mais que c'est un objectif
encore une fois pour garantir l'égalité
des droits
le deuxième point c'est le pouvoir
réglementaire locale donc on connaît
cette impression de vivre parfois en
absurdistan quand on a des règlements
nationaux extrêmement strictes
extrêmement uniformisant qui font que
parfois dans certains pour certains
sujets et dans certains territoires
l'action publique est juste irréalisable
donc nous nous souhaitons pouvoir donner
aux collectivités locales un pouvoir
réglementaire qui encadre et c'est à
dire ça n'est pas une liberté qui est
donné à tous les territoires d'organiser
leurs propres dispositions législatives
territoriales si je puis dire
mais dans le cadre d'un encadrement et
d'une autorisation donnée par le
législateur on va permettre on va
permettre que des territoires puissent
adapter des dispositions ça peut être
vrai en matière de logement ça peut être
vrai en matière d' aides qui sont donnés
à certaines structures
le troisième article un article alors
dont on ne perçoit pas vraiment
l'importance et concerne cet objet qui a
été créée par la loi map tam qui hélas
été happé la conférence territoriale de
l'action publique sur lequel les élus
ont beaucoup de choses à dire ce que je
rappelle que dans la consultation que le
sénat organise
et qui a réuni 3200 avis là c'était ap a
été évoquée c'est un espace de dialogue
entre l'ensemble des collectivités d'un
territoire régional ça nous semble
extrêmement important que ces
collectivités territoriales et un espace
de rencontres et d'échangés parce
qu'elles sont amenées à travailler
ensemble mais que nous ne souhaitons pas
que c'était ap se voit confier des
missions particulières qui viendrait
entraver la libre administration
d'autres collectivités
c'est pourquoi nous avons rejeté
l'article tel qu'il est proposé par le
gouvernement mais que par contre nous
avons bien retenu cette idée proposée
par le département de capacité de
collectivités a délégué une coupe une
partie de leurs compétences à une autre
collectivité je prends l'exemple de
l'économie qui est de la compétence de
la région
on peut imaginer que là où c'est utile
la région de perm est dans un cadre très
strict un département d'intervenir dans
le champ de l'économie de proximité et
nous attendons le gouvernement sur ce
sujet parce qu'il ne peut pas y avoir de
décentralisation et d'agilité si on
refuse cette possibilité de souplesse
pour sortir d'un carcan qui trop souvent
a rendu les choses difficiles et créer
de la tension entre les élus c'est
pourquoi dans le même esprit nous allons
permettre ce que nous avions déjà voté
ici au sénat
c'est le transfert à la carte de
compétence au sein des ep si les
compétences obligatoires ont leur
utilité mais sans doute que certaines
mal apprécié d'une manière nationale
méritent d'être affinés dans leur
répartition au niveau territorial et je
donne un exemple dont on parle souvent
et commence à devenir rayonnant c'est le
fameux nids de poule dans la voirie
ensuite sur la décentralisation alors là
l'excès timidité
est assez remarquable puisque vous savez
que la loi a confié à des collectivités
des compétents je prends l'exemple de la
compétence sociale et notamment autour
de l'enfance et la petite enfance des
départements je pense aux obligations
qui sont faites aujourd'hui aux
collectivités sur la restauration dans
les cantines des collèges et des lycées
les deux dernières semaines au sénat on
a beaucoup parlé de sahorre un président
de région qui a une obligation de
respecter un approvisionnement en
produits bio en cirque en circuit court
dans les cantines de ces lycées est
incapable de répondre à cette obligation
puisque le gestionnaire n'est pas un
personnel du conseil régional mais il
dépend du directeur du lycée qui est
impersonnelle d'état et que nous nous
pensons que c'est quand même assez
comment dire astucieux c'est le minimum
que l'on puisse penser de confier à
celui qui a les obligations de faire les
choses y compris les ressources humaines
nous proposons la même chose sur la
médecine sur la médecine scolaire et
aussi pour les personnels de direction
et adjoints des établissements petite
petite enfance et enfin sur le champ de
la cohérence et de l'efficacité
nous proposons que la région qui a la
compétence économie qui intervient aussi
dans le champ de la formation la région
puissent coordonner tout le service à
l'emploi qu'ils soient de l'état où
qu'ils soient de la responsabilité
territoriale
je vous remercie oui je vais m'efforcer
d'être très sainte et deux mois plus
brefs
enfin ici un mig et elles n'ont juste si
je devais résumer à mon tour en faisant
siens les propos qui ont été tenus par à
ma collègue françoise gatel je dirais
que ce texte aurait pu finalement
être une rencontre entre la cohérence
sénatoriales et l'incohérence
gouvernementale deux mots pour illustrer
ce propos la cohérence sénatoriales
parce que finalement vous retrouvez dans
ce texte tout ce que le sénat n'a cessé
de dire de redire que ce soit lors du
vote de la loi nôtre je pense notamment
à la volonté que nous portons depuis
longtemps de demander à ce que les
régions soient chefs de file en matière
d'emploi et d'activité économique parce
que quand on parle de décentralisation
le dire c'est bien le faire c'est encore
un peu mieux et en le président buffet
l'a rappelé les mesures en matière de
décentralisation sont relativement
timide pour ne pas dire évanescente dans
ce texte la cohérence sénatoriales aussi
parce que vous retrouverez dans ce texte
tout ce que nous portons ce que nous
avons proposé il y a un an et est ce que
nous rappelions lors de la précédente
conférence de presse il y a quatre
semaines notamment et alain milon il
reviendra sur les conséquences que nous
avons tirées de cette crise sanitaire
notamment au travers de la gouvernance
sur les agences régionales de santé
cohérence encore parce que vous
retrouverez les dispositions que ces
sons de rappeler au gouvernement sur les
questions de l'eau et de
l'assainissement qui ne sont pas des
caprices sénatoriaux mais le reflet de
ce que vivent nos élus et de ce que
demandent nos élus sur le territoire
cohérence encore sénatoriales parce que
lorsque l'on parle et que l'on veut
tirer des conséquences de cette crise
sanitaire
à l'évidence il faut un mouvement de
déconcentration qui accompagne le
mouvement décentralisation et comment
peut-on agir ainsi si l'on ne donne pas
si on ne renforce pas considérablement
les pouvoirs notamment de dérogation des
préfets de départements ain cohérence
gouvernementale parce qu'à l'évidence on
ne peut pas parler de cohérence
gouvernementale quand ce texte porte un
dé qui est celui de la déconcentration
et que la ministre de montchanin
viennent nous annoncer qu'elle regrette
la timidité lors d'une audition des
mesures relatives à des concentrations
mais qu'elle nous donne rendez-vous
heureusement dans un mois lorsque le
premier ministre castex annoncera avec
elle
une multitude de décisions et de prises
de position sur la déconcentration lors
d'un prochain comité interministériel
vous en conviendrez il n'y a pas mieux
pour tuer un texte que de nous annoncer
que finalement l'essentiel de la
déconcentration se passera or du texte
qui porte justement un souffle en
matière de déconcentration incohérences
gouvernementale disons les choses très
clairement
car l'une des principales mesures de ce
texte c'est notamment le transfert des
routes nationales vers les départements
et les régions et qu'à l'instant où nous
vous parlons nous ne connaissons pas
encore alors que nous avons voté hier
pris des positions en commission pour
arrêter le texte la liste des routes qui
ont vocation à être définitivement
transféré de l'état vers les
collectivités territoriales je le dis
avec regret parce que nous ne cessons de
le dire texte a pretext le travail du
parlement est considérablement abîmé
voir piétiner
s'agissant de ce texte par cette
incohérence gouvernementales et que nous
ne pouvons pas j'allais dire expertise
et un texte qui est pour nous essentiel
nous n'avons cessé de le dire une des
réponses à la crise que nous vivons à la
crise démocratique à l'abstention
malheureusement que nous avons eues a
dénombré c'est aussi le sentiment que
nos concitoyens réclament toujours plus
de proximité souhaitent comprendre lire
l'action publique et comment mieux
comprendre et mieux lire qu en
actionnant jaillir des mesures de
décentralisation c'est notre volonté
c'est une volonté que nous n'avons cessé
ici d'affirmer au sénat qui trouve
encore des propositions très concrètes
dans ce texte
enfin et pour finir un mot sur la
simplification
le conseil d'état lui même a dû
sacrifier inde et celui des
complexification pourtant les élus ne
cessent de le dire stop aux stocks et
aux flux de normes
il faut simplifier or je vous invite à
regarder les mesures dites de
simplification dans ce texte
la plupart n'apportent quasiment rien et
une grande partie que nous avons
d'ailleurs supprimé hier en commission
sont de nature à complexifier les choses
à
apporter encore des contraintes
supplémentaires et des charges nouvelles
aux collectivités et singulièrement aux
communes vous savez qu'on est très
attaché ici automnale france communal
cessons de le dire très attaché au
pouvoir de subsidiarité au principe de
subsidiarité aux collectivités je crois
qu'à un moment donné
malheureusement quand on parle du
souffle absents dans ce texte sur les 3
d je crois que malheureusement les faits
nous donnent raison et finir par vous
dire que il y à un mois pourtant devant
vous nous avions abordé ce texte avec
une volonté d'avancer
je crois que nous n'avons cessé que ce
soit sur engagement proximité que ce
soit sur la simplification en matière
d'expérimentation d'apporter une volonté
de co écriture d'action en soutien de
toute initiative gouvernementale qui
irait dans le bon sens nous n'avons
jamais fait preuve d'une volonté
d'obstruction
c'est encore vrai aujourd'hui c'est
pourquoi nous attendons enfin du
gouvernement qu'il nous donne des
réponses à nos questions et surtout
qu'il nous permette de prendre en compte
qu'ils permettent de prendre en compte
par dont des demandes qui sont des
demandes insistantes de la part du sénat
oui merci messieurs président en ce qui
concerne donc plus particulièrement la
commission des affaires sociales nous
avons eu à examiner 10 articles de ce
projet de loi
dix articles relatifs à la santé ainsi
qu'aux compétences sociales et médico
social des collectivités territoriales
je dois dire que les dispositions que
nous avons eu à examiner ce sont plutôt
des dispositions disparates de qui sont
pour notre part de faible portée en tout
cas qui ne suivent pas toujours un fil
conducteur clair ainsi certains sujets
abordés par ce projet de loi seront par
la suite abordé de manière beaucoup plus
globale dans des projets doit beaucoup
plus important je pense en particulier
au projet devoir annoncer sur le grand
âge je sais pas quand est ce qu'il
arrivera vous non plus mais j'espère
qu'il arrivera un jour
et puis au projet de loi sur la
protection de l'enfance qui lui a déjà
été étudiée au niveau du conseil des
ministres ce qui concerne le projet doit
sur protection de l'enfance dois vous
dire par exemple que l'un des articles
de ce projet de loi 3ds qui nous est
présentée concerne les amène à limiter
les mineurs non accompagnés
et on retrouve cet article dans la
preuve dans la protection de l'enfance à
la virgule près et donc plus intéressant
pour nous ça c'est la commission des
lois qui ne décidera c'est pas la
commission affaires sociales mais de
voir si on peut pas plutôt discuter cet
article dans la protection de l'enfance
plutôt que dans la droite 3ds pour ce
qui nous concerne le volet relatif à la
santé
les deux articles importants son article
31 articles 32 le 31 revoir à la suite
de ce que nous avons connu pour la crise
qu'ovide la gouvernance des agences
régionales de santé
cet article 31 nous propose à l'issue
des travaux de l'assemblée nationale un
conseil d'administration plutôt qu'un
conseil de surveillance et nous sommes
d'accord sur le principe et trois élus
locaux font le faisant partie de ce
conseil d'administration nous sommes
allés beaucoup plus loin que l'assemblée
nationale puisque nous proposons nous
une co présidence des conseils
d'administration des ars une
coprésidence dirigé à la fois par le
président de la région et par le préfet
de région et nous proposons aussi que à
l'intérieur du conseil d'administration
les voix des élus locaux soit en nombre
égal aux voix des élus de l'état
enfin nous proposons surtout ce qui me
semble être aussi extrêmement important
c'est que le projet régional de santé
vous savez qu'il est en principe mis en
place pour cinq années ce projet
régional de santé ne soient plus soumis
pour avis simplement au conseil
d'administration mais soumis au vote
avec un vote positif votre négatif et si
le vote est négative n'a pas de
configuration
le directeur de rs doit revoir sa copie
pour le soumettre à nouveau au conseil
d'administration ça nous semble être
extrêmement important que ce prs soit
soumis à l'approbation du conseil
d'administration dans lequel je vous
rappelle il ya un nombre de voix égal
des élus locaux et des élus de la nation
pour ce qui est de l'article 32 qui est
le principe du financement par les
collectivités territoriales des
établissements de santé publics et
privés
nous avons considéré à la suite des
auditions de des maires des départements
et des régions que cet article était
dangereux dans la mesure où l'état
pourrait très bien pour financer un
projet demandé le cofinancement
et de la région et du département et de
la commune et si la commune est pas les
moyens de payer l'état pourrait dire va
coûter la commune ne veut pas payer donc
on fait pas le projet donc on a mis en
place une gradation dans les
financements les communes et les
départements peuvent financer des
financements des investissements
d'équipement et pas d'immobilier et
d'équipements de proximité la région
elle finançant les équipements de l'auto
nature régionale ou de nature nationale
en ce qui concerne évidemment les chu en
particulier quand on pense à un national
on pense au chu au centre hospitalier
universitaire pour ce qui est du volet
médico-social et à l'article 35 que la
commission des affaires sociales a
supprimé c'est la recentralisation du
rsa en expérimentation pour le
département de seine saint denis nous
sommes conscients que la
seine-saint-denis a besoin que cette
recentralisation se fasse il n'est pas
question pour nous de supprimer
définitivement mais nous avons dans
notre dans nos auditions demandé à
plusieurs reprises que nous ayons des
retours de l'expérimentation qui est
mise en place depuis 2010 9 à mayotte en
guadeloupe et à la réunion et nous
n'avons jamais eu aucune réponse
on ne sait pas combien il ya eu de rsa
depuis 19 depuis 2010 9 jusqu'en 2021
si ce nombre a augmenté si les
allocations augmenter si ce nombre a
diminué si la croatie ont diminué et
donc nous souhaitons savoir comment va
se passer ensuite il faut savoir qu'ici
à une recentralisation
nous souhaitons savoir comment vont se
faire payer des allocations est-ce que
c'est l'état seul qui plus est ce que
l'état va demander quand même une
participation département est ce que le
nombre de rsa va augmenter s'il augmente
qui va payer tout ça on ne sait pas donc
nous avons voulu supprimer cet article
en mettant le gouvernement au pied du
mur afin qu'il nous donne plus de
précisions
au moins en séance faute de nous l'avoir
donnée dans le cadre de nos auditions
pour ce qui est de l'article 36 il
s'agit de la compétence départementale
de coordination développement d'habitat
inclusif
nous avons a sorti cet article de levier
plus opérationnels qui sont d'ailleurs
suggéré dans le rapport de piveteau wolf
robe
enfin je voudrais terminer par l'article
nous avons supprimé la possibilité pour
l'état de donner la responsabilité
totale des pupilles de l'état aux
départements pour une raison toute
simple c'est qu'encore une fois c'est un
article qui vient se greffer comme ça
dans une loi de 3ds et qu' il ya une loi
qui va arriver à un projet de loi qui va
arriver en principe en septembre sur la
protection de l'enfance et là aussi les
pupilles c'est le parti de la protection
de l'enfance donc nous entendons nous
attendons plutôt le projet doit de
monsieur adrien attaqué pour faire voir
ce qu'il en fera donc la supprimer de la
con on en rediscutera en septembre voilà
en gros la façon dont la commission des
affaires sociales en accord avec les
rapporteurs d'arnaud et date elle a
travaillé sur le sujet mais c'est le
président mes chers collègues rapporteur
mesdames messieurs les journalistes sur
les articles 9 13 61 et 62 dont j'avais
la charge les amendements adoptés par la
commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durables
s'inscrivent dans trois axes renforcer
les outils mis à la disposition des
collectivités territoriales dans le
domaine des infrastructures de transport
mais ancré dans les territoires les
politiques sanitaires et
environnementales et assurer
l'effectivité des dispositions du projet
de loi
d'abord sur le transfert des petites
lignes ferroviaires aux régions nous
avons souhaité garantir la cohérence du
réseau ferré national grâce à la
transmission d'un socle commun de règles
de sécurité et de maintenance aux futurs
gestionnaires de ces lignes de desserte
fine afin de favoriser la qualité du
service la commission a également adopté
un amendement permettant région de
conclure un contrat de performance avec
le futur gestionnaire d'infrastructure
sur le modèle du contrat de performance
qui existe entre l'état et sncf réseau
ensuite la commission a souhaité donner
plus de porter au rôle de chef de file
des régions dans le domaine de la
protection de la biodiversité en leur
conférant le pouvoir de proposer la
création de sites natura 2000 et en les
associant mieux au processus
désignation de ces sites enfin la
commission a fait le choix de recalibrer
le champ d'application du régime de
protection dont font l'objet les
alignements d'arbres en excluant les
voies de communications privées afin
d'assurer un meilleur équilibre entre
protection de l'environnement et du
patrimoine paysager et respect du droit
de propriété j'ajoute que notre
commission adoptée 14 autres amendements
sur les articles dont elle était saisie
pour avis dont 13 faisait l'objet d'une
position commune avec les commissions
des lois et des affaires sociales par
lesquels ils ont été repris je citerai
les propositions les plus emblématiques
dont certaines ont été inspirées par le
rapport de 50 propositions françoise
d'athènes en a parlé
pour le plein exercice des libertés
locales publié par le sénat en juillet
2020 prévoir l'information des
collectivités en amont du transfert des
routes nationales à la carte afin de
leur permettre de se décider en
connaissance de cause notamment
s'agissant de l'état du réseau
allonger le délai laissé à ses
collectivités pour se porter candidate
au transfert renforcer la représentation
des élus locaux au sein du conseil
d'administration de l'ademe et drs
afin de renforcer la proximité de
l'action de ces établissements publics
et enfin réformé le serema pour lui
conférer un fonctionnement plus efficace
et permettre un partage équitable des
outils d'ingénierie territoriale entre
l'état et des collectivités voient là
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les points essentiels que je tenais à
porter à votre connaissance mais sur
l'importance des plantations se sont
terminées le vif matin elle répondre en
apportant à vos questions si toutefois
si vous en aviez naturellement mais pas
de questions ah bon madame oui par les
biens dans le micro faut appuyer sur le
bouton rouge voilà ok je c'est parfait
bonjour marie guitton pour contexte que
vous n'avez toujours pas de nouvelles du
gouvernement visiblement vous n'en avez
pas effectivement il ya pas eu beaucoup
d'amendements du
déposé à ce stade vous attendez quoi le
dialogue est complètement rompu vous
avez quand même une idée de ce qu'il va
faire non c'est absolument pas dans le
dialogue ou la capacité des changes
d'ailleurs on n'a cessé de saluer les
contacts que nous pouvions avoir avec
jacqueline gourault je crois qu'il y a
malheureusement plusieurs ministres qui
sont concernés par ce texte et on
n'arrive absolument pas avoir de
cohérence je veux pas trahir de secret
puisque l'audition était publique madame
gouro s'engage à nous donner la carte
des routes transférer et auditions ici
même dans cette salle il y a une semaine
monsieur djebbari nous explique que nous
n'aurons pas la carte puisque la carte
nous l'aurons une fois le texte voté et
les des crêperies peut se demander
pardon de le dire aussi clairement s'il
ya un pilote dans l'avion
il ya un moment donné on ne peut pas sur
un texte aussi important je vous
rappelle quand même je l'avais précisé
que ce texte c'est pas n'importe quel
texte ce texte était tout simplement un
engagement à quelques encablures d'ici
dans la salle clemenceau du président
emmanuel macron lors du lancement de la
conférence nationale des territoires
l'engagement avait été pris d'un texte
qui avait vocation à reprendre des
demandes du sénat pour ça que souvent
caricature un peu nos positions
notamment sur des sujets comme eau et
assainissement
mais pardon d'opposer au gouvernement
une constance sénatoriales ce que nous
avons intégré et introduit dans ce texte
nous le disons depuis 3 4 ans et les
élus des territoires pardon de le dire
peut-être petit des connexions
d'ailleurs entre le gouvernement et les
élus des territoires à un moment donné
ça n'est que le reflet de ce que les
associations d'élus qui sont venus ici
même pour être auditionnées dont cessé
de dire et puisque des fois on nous fait
des procès d'intention d'écouter les
seules associations d'élus nous avons
auditionné sur la question des routes
les vice présidents des régions qui
étaient les plus exposées les plus
concernés par le transfert des routes
notamment pour ne citer que cet exemple
là et tous tous convergent sur la
position qui est qui et celle du sénat
donc quand on veut faire un texte qui a
une volonté
décentralisatrice de porter la
déconcentration comme finalement cet
équilibre pour parvenir à une juste
décentralisation faut-il encore un
moment donné qu'on s'appuie sur ce qui
vient de se passer avec la crise
sanitaire durant plus d'un an dans notre
pays pour en tirer des conclusions
quelque part en phase avec la réalité de
ce que vivent nos territoires
et puis tout simplement en donnant une
forme d'agilité qui permet justement
d'assurer cette proximité que ce soit au
préfet de département que ce soit aux
collectivités qui veulent de plus en
plus pour voir s'organiser sans être
complètement régie ou enfermés dans les
logiques qui sont celles de la loi note
c'est à dire à chaque compétence à
chaque collectivité une compétence or
aujourd'hui il y a nombre d'exemples qui
montrent qu'il faut de l'agilité qu'il
faut permettre de travailler par
délégation de compétence entre les
départements les régions
que ce soit des deux façons descendants
ou ascendants
donc nous on n'est pas fermé mais quand
on propose un texte avec un titre aussi
ronflants quand on rentre dans le texte
qu'on s'aperçoit que finalement c'est
une approche qui est très sectoriel
parce qu'en réalité on ne parle pas de
déconcentration ou de décentralisation
on parle d'urbanisme de transfert de
route d'aspe sanitaires sociaux
éducatifs et de simplification vous
voyez il ya déjà il ya déjà un schisme
mais ça à la limite c'est pas très grave
comme l'a dit françoise avec une
justesse absolue nous ce qu'on cherche
et l'efficience donc à la limite et on
l'a dit on l'a dit au début de ce texte
et pour qu'il y ait une efficience
faut-il qu'ils aient encore une capacité
des changes et des couteaux on a le
sentiment que il y à une écoute v que l'
écoute ne débouche pas sur une prise en
compte des demandes du sénat qui me
paraissent pas être outrancières ou
aller à l'encontre des aspirations du
duo allait rapidement ce conte une
nouvelle question
2 aujourd'hui illustre bien je crois
l'enjeu pour le l'enjeu pour le
gouvernement c'est à dire il ne faut pas
isolés et traités en soliste les
questions de santé les questions
d'éducation l'objectif c'est que
l'action publique soit efficace et qu'il
faut donc que dans cette polyphonie
interministérielle qui manque un peu
d'harmonie
il y un chef d'orchestre qui choie
désigné et qui approche les choses d'une
manière cohérente et intelligent c'est à
dire on retrouve ces poussées on va dire
d'ambition de pouvoir interministérielle
qui vient bloquer l'efficacité des
choses donc nous on espère que d'ici
mercredi à une révolution culturelle au
gouvernement au culturel une question je
crois monsieur et puis ensuite monsieur
roger le monde
bon on a tous compris que l'ambition
principale de ce texte porté sur le dé
de différenciation je voulais savoir il
ya plusieurs questions qui se posent je
voulais savoir en quoi vous avait accru
la portée de
de cet article exactement précisément
ensuite 10e à ouaga tels que enfin ce
que j'ai compris c'est que vous tiriez
quand même un bilan assez mitigé des
conférences territoriales de l'action
publique
quelles nouvelles possibilités de
délégations de compétence vous souhaitez
accordés entre les collectivités et j'ai
compris quand vous dites nous attendons
le gouvernement sur ce point que c'était
un point de discussion important pour
vous entre entre le sénat et le
gouvernement est bon je vais pas je veux
pas être trop long mais quand même une
question sur la serre matière de
décentralisation du transfert de la
compétence du service public de l'emploi
aux régions est ce que toutes les
régions sont demandeuses de ce transfert
voilà je me limite à ça pour l'instant
l'amg at elle répondu et puis ensuite ce
sera votre tour
merci merci monsieur le président sur la
différenciation si je puis dire d'une
manière simple nous y allons assez fort
puisque nous nous partons d'un principe
qui est celui auquel nous croyons
beaucoup et qui soutenus par les par les
associations d'élus et par toutes les
consultations que nous avons fait nous
introduisons des possibilités de
délégations de compétence d'une
collectivité à une autre aujourd'hui la
loi dit la compétence économie n'est que
le fait de la région nous nous
permettons avec ce texte que si la
région veut délégué un département un
soutien par exemple au commerce de
proximité ou que sais-je nous offrons
cette possibilité par le biais de
conventions
deuxième chose extrêmement importante
qui est une ré
solution alors culturel en l'occurrence
pour certains c'est l'intérêt
communautaire dans les métropoles
aujourd'hui dans les métropoles comme
vous transférez quand la métropole prend
une compétence de manière obligatoire
elle apprend tout donc je vais redonner
l'exemple de la voirie la voirie a été
donnée aux métropoles parce qu'elles ont
la compétence mobilité il est important
que vous maîtrisiez les routes sur
lesquelles vont circuler ou des bus ou
le tram
sauf que on a aussi donné à la métropole
le nid-de-poule encore une fois qui est
dans la 50e commune où il n'y a jamais
un bus qui passent et aujourd'hui c'est
la métropole
keane énorme machine parfois très
lointaine qui doit intervenir sur ce qui
est une compétence de proximité donc
nous nous permettons que dans les
métropoles si les élus le veulent encore
une fois nous ne contraignons pas nous
donnons la liberté la capacité de faire
les élus puissent définir la notion
d'intérêt d'intérêt métropolitain
donc c'est ce que nous faisons c'est
vraiment extrêmement puissant c'est un
cadre qui au lieu de contraindre permet
et permettent d'exercer l'action
publique à partir d'un principe très
simple et c'est ça qui devrait tous nous
guider subsidiarité c'est à dire laisser
faire au bon niveau la chose qui est à
faire et nous ne remettons pas en cause
l'intercommunalité les compétences ou
les périmètres
nous venons donner ce que les élus
demandent parce que l'action publique
est bloqué c'est la souplesse sur les
serbes sur le public de l'emploi lors
sans doute qu'on a un écart avec le avec
le gouvernement nous nous pensons que la
région doit tout au moins exercé un rôle
de coordination pourquoi c'est parce que
la région est compétente en matière
d'économie intervient aussi dans les
champs de la formation et que pour être
cohérent il faut que celui qui a la
compétence et la totalité des leviers de
la chaîne
oui bonjour marion mourgue le figaro
vous avez tous souligné le manque
d'ambition de ce texte est le fait aussi
que le gouvernement n'a pas l'air
d'entendre ce que vous préconisez
qu'est ce qui se passe dans un mois si
justement vos travaux et vos
recommandations n'ont pas été entendus
tout simplement on a été très clair
depuis le début c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui on ne donnait pas un chèque
en blanc on partait d'un postulat qui
était un postulat favorable à toute
démarche qui va vers plus de
décentralisation comme l'a dit françoise
gatel à l' instant de déconcentration
qui respecter l'esprit du texte pour les
raisons que j'ai évoquées c'est à dire
qu'il s'agissait d'un engagement de la
part du président de la république
réaffirmé par le premier ministre castex
et on a d'ailleurs salué le fait que ce
texte arrive au parlement donc
aujourd'hui on peut surtout pas nous
faire un procès en sorcellerie
considérant que nous soyons là pour
faire de l'obstruction donc on va être
très pragmatique c'est à dire que on a
clairement dit que s'agissant des sujets
liés à la loi sru a au sujet qui évoqué
alain milon aux conditions de transfert
des routes nationales
comment voulez vous que nous on valide
un texte qui ne définirai ni les
conditions dans lesquelles vont s'opérer
au deuil
au delà même d'ailleurs des cartes des
routes parce que on peut considérer que
les cartes des routes c'est un accord
entre l'état et les collectivités
par contre toutes les collectivités nous
disent attention vous sénat veiller à ce
que les conditions de transfert soit
clairement édictées qu'on sache où on va
parce qu'il s'agit pas qu'on dise oui
oui on peut récupérer la rn102 en
ardèche et en haute-loire on veut
récupérer la rn88 entre lyon et toulouse
sans savoir vers quoi on va quels moyens
nous aurons et surtout parce que vous
allez avoir des transferts de personnel
de l'état vers les collectivités tous
les agents des dires donc vous imaginez
bien que c'est quand même une révolution
pour les collectivités ça c'est un vrai
mouvement décentralisateur et comme tout
mouvement il faut qu'on sache où on va
et nous ce qu'on dit c'est que et c'est
d'ailleurs un
vraiment l'adn du sénat et nous l'avons
réaffirmé on est très attaché à l'étude
d'impact a à connaître les conditions
qui vont prévaloir à ces transferts et
surtout à la capacité derrière d'évaluer
on n'a cessé de dire que nous on est
aussi très intéressé par l'évaluation
exposé c'est à dire c'est bien d'avoir
des études d'impact mais faut-il encore
être en capacité de faire de
l'évaluation interne et on peut pas
faire d'évaluation si on n'a pas des
conditions dans lesquelles doivent
s'opérer les transferts donc tout ça
pour dire que si les conditions ne sont
pas remplies
à l'évidence et nous n'avons cessé de le
dire nous n'irons pas et ne m'appartient
pas de le dire mais en tout cas c'est ce
que nous n'avons cessé de dire
collectivement vers d une cmp qui sera
qui sera conclusif sache mais on l'a
clairement dit au niveau gouvernemental
a fixé ses exigences dans le texte
l'assemblée nationale s'en saisira on
verra ce qu'elle fait de ses exigences
on peut bien imaginer que à un moment et
c'est normal dans le processus
parlementaire
il y aura un échange quand tous les cas
le niveau d'exigence voulue par le sénat
sera défendu fermement défendu compte
tenu à la fois des enjeux territoriaux
deux expertises qui est la nôtre d'une
part et compte tenu du travail qui a
déjà été fait dans la maison comme ça
l'idée monsieur bonjour tiré du pont
pour contexte j'ai bien compris que vous
aviez été attachée au principe de à la
carte pour les compétences il ne m'a pas
semblé que certaines associations d'élus
étaient favorables cela la carte je
pense notamment à la dcf la france
urbaine s'agissant des métropoles est ce
que vous ne craignez pas de réveiller
une guerre des strates entre les
collectivités
alors nous nous sommes extrêmement
pacifistes et nous sommes profondément
lucide
moi je veux bien qu'on se cramponne à
des principes dès lors qu'ils ont fait
la preuve de leur efficacité
nous ne serions pas là aujourd'hui avec
vous ni à passer deux semaines aig le
gouvernement si les lois territoriale
précédentes la loi no 2
madame avait été lumineuses aller dans
les territoires
partout vous voulez et très librement
vous allez trouver partout des élus
plutôt vertueux qui sont pas
naturellement grognon qui se sont
retrouvés enfermés dans des
intercommunalités parce que appelons les
choses par leur nom qui ont été trop
pesant et qui était en peser par des
transferts obligatoire de compétences
alors que ici au sénat et alors ne
faisons pas au sénat une guerre de
tranchées avec cette histoire ce pas
vous hein mais je sais que ma parole
peut être entendu au delà d'ici ne
faisons pas au sénat le procès d'un
excès d'amour de la commune au détriment
de l'interco le fait communal est une
réalité dans ce pays
et dieu sait si les mouvements des
gilets jaunes le l'élection encore
fréquenter des mers montre que la
proximité si ce qui va sauver cette
cohésion sociale maintenant nous nous
défendons l'intercommunalité parce
qu'elle est vertueuse est elle efficace
on en a besoin mais pour ça faut qu'elle
soit vertueuse c'est-à-dire qu'elles
soient bien dimensionné et que le
nid-de-poule expliquez moi comment une
métropole revendiqué l'intérêt du
rayonnement dany poule quand elle loi à
la fois impulser des des thématiques en
matière de recherche en matière
d'économie est ce que le nid-de-poule
n'est pas mieux gérer ce niveau là donc
nous ne détricote ont rien du tout et
sincèrement on a un dialogue plutôt
opposés et exigeant avec la dcf qui est
une association extrêmement raisonnable
est extrêmement performante il ya aucun
lien que la femme mon propos mais moi
j'ai été longtemps et je m'entends très
bien avec sauf que nous on défend pas
telle catégorie de collectivités ou de
groupement nous on défend l'efficacité
de l'action publique
avec ce principe de subsidiarité
soyons justes intelligent faisons les
choses simples efficacement donc
certainement de la dcr à moins de
séduction pour les sénateurs que nous
sommes parce que on nous prête une image
un peu caricatural et sincèrement dans
ce texte je mets au défi de la dcf
d'avoir l'impression qu on détricote
quand on vient juste mettre l'intérêt
communautaire
c'est juste de la souplesse que l'on
mais pour que ça se passe mieux
si une interco garder toute la
compétence est la garde si ça ne marche
pas ce qu'on peut lui permettre de
respirer
l'expression consacrée de l'intelligence
territoriale
oui parce que l'on essaye de faire au
sénat c'est un peu de cette nature fille
c'est à dire de rendre de prendre les
mesures qui sont lus et les moyens qui
sont les plus efficaces au service les
habitants du territoire
on sait bien tous ici ils ont tous été
des élus locaux maires tous en
responsabilité que la première des
obligations qu'on lui demande c'est de
remplir les causes du quotidien et de
les remplir dans les meilleures
conditions possibles les grands projets
globalement on y arrive mais c'est le
quotidien qui est le plus fondamental
il n'y a pas de grand projet possible
s'il ya pas de quotidiens parfaitement
sa de politique quotidienne parfaitement
henry c'est la règle et on est dans cet
état d'esprit
juste pour apporter un mot parce que
souvent on discute on a l'impression
qu'on s'envoie des vérités à la tête moi
j'invite juste à regarder les faits
simplement les faits tout ce qu'on a dit
depuis le vote de la loi notre s'est
avéré une réalité quand on a dit que les
intercommunalités xxl ça ne marcherait
pas eh ben ça y est ça commence c'est à
dire qu'avec les possibilités offertes
dans l'engagement et proximité on
commence à avoir des dents morbihan des
intercommunalités qui veulent se scinder
parce que quand on fait du trop grand
trop vaste ça ne fonctionne pas le big
is beautiful en réalité ça ne marche pas
dans un temps nos concitoyens veulent
comprendre élire l'action publique
si vous faites des immenses région qui
parleront demain à d immenses
intercommunalités vous diluez la
proximité et ça ne fonctionne pas les
gouvernances pléthorique on le sait très
bien ça ne fonctionne pas et nous ce
qu'on dit simplement c'est qu'on arrive
aujourd'hui dans un moment dans un temps
politique important où il ya deux façons
de lire la carte de
institutions et l'avenir institutionnel
c'est soit on fait confiance aux élus et
on donne un peu plus de liberté
d'agilité est capacité via la
différenciation territoriales à
s'organiser
considérant qu'on a des problématiques
territoriales qui ne sont pas du même
niveau dès lors qu'on est en ardèche
dans le bas-rhin où dans le morbihan
parce qu'il ya un passé il ya une
culture il ya une histoire un milan et
dans un département où un nombre de
communes qui est bien inférieur à ce
qu'on peut avoir en seine maritime c'est
un rapport de 1,8 voilà tout ça c'est le
fruit d'une histoire mais c'est aussi
une réalité
soit on considère que eh ben il faut
prendre un marteau et on tape sur la
tête des élus pour les contraindre à
rentrer dans un cadre ça pardon c'est à
mon avis la déviance de la loi notre et
ben nous on est contre ça antonio
rodriguez afp je vous prie de m'excuser
je suis arrivé en retard et ce retard
explique peut-être mauvaise perception
de ce que je vais dire mais l'impression
que j'ai depuis que je suis arrivé c'est
que vous avez ce que vous présentez
c'est un chamboulement complet de cette
rocade des ça commence déjà par le nom
alors je ne sais pas si ça vient du
sénat ou si ça vient du ministère la 4d
devient 3ds étant simplification mais je
me demandais si c'était passé n'a
également
est ce que est ce que est ce que
est-ce qu effectivement c'est un
chamboule-tout que vous proposez et le
risque que vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure en répondant à ma collègue c'est
que ce projet de loi en l'état ne voit
jamais le jour
et j'aurai une deuxième question ensuite
aux régionales et départementales de qui
viennent d'avoir lieu
me demandais si vous aviez une mesure où
peut-être concrète une idée de mesures
qui renforcerait l'attrait des
collectivités qui renforcerait
évidemment la participation lors des
prochaines élections
il ya deux façons de voir les choses
je sincèrement quand on enterre on a pas
on a rien détruit on n'a rien démoli on
a enrichi
on a achevé cette architecture bancal
mais sincèrement on la nourrit et
parlez-en aux élus vous allez voir même
le gouvernement le reconnaît
donc on a approvisionné ce texte on l'a
accueilli d'une manière positive
encore une fois même la ministre a salué
l'accueil qu'ils avaient été faits au
sénat on a reproché à la ministre acti
me dit et on lui a dit on va s'occuper
du reste mais on est dans un état
d'esprit constructif
troisième point moi je sincèrement la
question que vous pose est comment
ramène les citoyens aux urnes ont je
pense pas qu'on va la cre était
aujourd'hui par contre sincèrement le
jour où tous les français jusqu'au
dernier kilomètre verront qu'il ya de
l'efficacité encore une fois je repars
du fameux nids de poule qui peut être
caricatural mais que le nid-de-poule est
bouché que les personnes âgées ont des
solutions qu'il y a des mobilités que le
président du département
il peut avoir autorité sur son personnel
ce qui n'a pas aujourd'hui pour
s'occuper de la petite enfance
ça ira peut être mieux aussi dont 4 d
c'est aujourd'hui un peu invisible pour
les gens parce que c'est de l'
architecture c'est un mécano dont nous
différenciation des concentrations sont
des outils pour un objectif qui est le
nôtre et c'est le seul qu'on poursuit et
le gouvernement il doit certainement
avoir le même que l'autre soit possible
autrement c'est l'efficacité sert qu'on
soit ici nos concitoyens et sincèrement
moi je pense qu'il ya urgence parce
qu'on peut pas passer notre temps à
faire des lois territoriales à les
corriger et revenir tout le temps est
donc aujourd'hui c'est l'heure de vérité
pour le gouvernement comme pour nous et
donc le message il est clair nous on
apporte des choses qui sont avérés il
appartiendra à chacun qui a un rôle à
jouer de l'entendre et construisent
ensemble une solution positive pour
répondre déjà la question 3ds c'est pas
c'est pas le sénat c'est le conseil
d'état qui a considéré justement que le
death que j'ai eu ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure en préambule que le dd
complexification ils étaient vides de
sens donc il valait mieux l'appeler
simplification et donc ça a donné quatre
des trous puis trois puis 3ds
[Applaudissements]
sincèrement si on est honnête je pense
pas qu'il faille attendre de ce texte
j'ai dit un outil qui permettra de
passer de 30% de participation à 60%
demain et je pense que la crise allait
beaucoup plus profonde cll elle met en
avant ce une forme de défiance vis-à-vis
des élus c'est évident en revanche ce
qui est une certitude
et vous aurez pu l'observer dans
certaines régions ce qui a concentré
l'intérêt des électeurs n'étaient pas
des enjeux nationaux
heureusement et vous allez me dire pour
une élection où un scrutin local mais ce
qui intéresse de plus en plus nos
concitoyens ce sont les problématiques
locales
regardez la question du grand test avec
la question de la collectivité
européenne d'alsace avec le
positionnement de la ministre klinkert
par rapport à jean rottner les sujets
qui ont intéressé les électeurs dans
cette région c'est qu'elle est il
advenir de la collectivité européenne
d'alsace quel est son avenir plus
d'alsace monde alsace et on voit bien
que ce sont des sujets de plus en plus
structurant donc la lecture locale
elle permet de re donner le sentiment à
nos concitoyens qu'il ya des enjeux qui
sont des enjeux territoriaux et le
deuxième point et c'est notre ambition
c'est que la décentralisation tout ça ce
sont des grands thermes
mais derrière c'est quoi c'est la
capacité de donner à nos concitoyens le
sentiment que la prise de décision
qu'une partie de la prise de décision ne
leur échappe plus parce qu'en fait elle
est prise dans leur préfecture de
département dans leur préfecture de
région et qu'ils ont une capacité à lire
un peu mieux je dis pas beaucoup mieux
mais un peu mieux cette action publique
ou en tout cas d'avoir accès à celles et
ceux qui la prennent donc est sage et
dire on le vit tous les jours dans nos
territoires dans nos départements dans
nos régions et l'ensemble des sénateurs
ici pourrait le dire mais des députés
comme comme des élus locaux
je crois que nos concitoyens ils ont
envie d'avoir un interlocuteur c'est
pour ça que nous préférons le préfet de
département préfet de région dans la
capacité qu'il a coordonné l'action
publique notamment en période de crise
quand il a fallu mettre en place des
protocoles sanitaires l'acheminement des
masques quand il faut traiter des
questions environnementales quand il
faut traiter des questions de soutien
financier aux collectivités
parce que c'est tout simplement ça
répond à une logique de proximité et ça
je pense que c'est pas la réponse mais
c'est une partie de la réponse du fait
que nos concitoyens se détournent un peu
parce qu'ils n'ont plus le sentiment
d'avoir accès à la prise de décision
puis habitants de tel ou tel territoire
ce qui m'intéresse de savoir si
l'interlocuteur que j'ai en face de moi
qui s'appelle le maire ou un autre lui
est en capacité de répondre à mon
problème de redu mon rôle c'est assez
simple et assez basique mais en réalité
c'est ce qui crée le lien de confiance
et c'est ce qui crée le fait que les
maisons les concitoyens à une
participation importante aux élections
municipales parce qu'ils sont attachés
qu'ils ont cette proximité
l'enjeu il est là je crois que changera
pas on n'augmentera pas une
participation aux élections
en changeant le les modalités de vote
tout en changeant telle ou telle chose
on augmentera la participation aux
élections comme on l'a aux élections
municipales par ce lien renforcé cette
simplicité cette clarification et cette
responsabilité
on peut me raconter beaucoup de choses
alors est-ce que parmi les journalistes
qui sont en visioconférence y at il des
demandes de parole ce que j'ai eu peur
d'avoir raté éventuellement une demande
donc un silence approbateur
monsieur nous en paix c'est par ce
projet voit ici a pas de demande d'amm
donc depuis depuis trois ans territoire
unis qui est largement parrainé par le
président du sénat gérard larcher n'a
cessé de dénoncer un mouvement de
recentralisation et de demander un grand
souffre un grand souffle de
décentralisation avec des demandes
bon c'est la culture le sport qu'elle
est enfin de tout l'été tout et hébron a
décentralisé sauf sauf les compétences
régaliennes et puis sincèrement dans le
texte la key2key l'issue de l'accord de
la commission
je retrouve pas ce grand souffle de
décentralisation ah bon certes il ya les
gestionnaires de collège et de lycée il
ya le service de l'emploi sur les routes
ou poupe
allons-y du boulot même s'il y avait des
demandes notamment du côté alsacien vous
en parliez tout à l'heure de de
récupérer des mais à part ça alors
qu'est-ce que ça traduit
est ce que finalement le sénat bon même
s'il a longtemps appuyé en fin du mois
son président les revendications de deux
territoires unis manet du juge que c'est
pas la priorité
est-ce que ça traduit le fait que même
entre les collectivités territoriales il
n'y a pas forcément un accord total sur
les compétences a décentralisé mais
enfin toujours est il que moi je
retrouve pas dans le texte de la
commission
ce grand souffle de décentralisation que
certes appelé de leurs voeux
je crois que ça tient tout simplement à
deux choses même si je pense que la
question du service public de l'emploi
s'est pas note que nous alors enfin je
m'empresse de dire qu'on est pour le
transfert des routes
simplement on considère que c'est pas au
sénat de dire quelles routes doivent
être transférés ont dit nous il faut que
les conditions de soi juste pour qu'on
aille peut-être demain vers plus encore
de transfert donc on n'est pas on n'est
pas contre simplement il faut quand même
revenir la génèse on est sur un projet
doit on n'est pas sur une ppl c'est pas
une initiative du du parlement et nous
on a dit qu'on était clairement en temps
et vous étiez là il ya quelques semaines
quand on a eu la conférence de presse on
a dit qu'on n'était pas là pour faire le
grand soir de la décentralisation qu'on
attendait justement du
ernement à travailler de concert et en
confiance pour nous enrichir le texte
il ne vous aura pas échappé que il y à
un article qui existe qui est l'article
40 qui quand même nous empêche nous de
proposer des transferts de compétences à
hue et à dia et que nombreux de nos
initiatives ont été stoppés freiner est
limitée par par cet article 40 et parce
que le champ du texte était relativement
vaste mais finalement peu étendus en
matière de proposition vis-à-vis de la
décentralisation donc nous on est là
pour enrichir on n'est pas là pour
révolutionner et encore une fois je
pense que nous attendions très
clairement du gouvernement alors on peut
rajouter quand même un élément parce que
on va on va se dire les choses telles
qu'elles sont proposées un texte sur la
décentralisation la déconcentration qui
vient percuter le calendrier électoral
après une période de crise sanitaire
tout le monde en conviendra
c'est pas le meilleur moment c'est pas
la meilleure façon de faire et c'est en
tout cas pas celle qui permet le plus de
sérénité et on l'a bien vu justement
vis-à-vis des associations que vous
évoquez pour certaines le président
n'est plus le président aujourd'hui
pour d'autres il y avait des
incertitudes s'agissant notamment de la
rfc huy le vin pardon et les conditions
je le dis encore une fois quand c'est
une priorité du chef de l'état en 2010
est malheureusement soit on anticipe ce
texte et on a bien vu pourquoi il n'a
pas pu être anticipé parce que tout le
monde n'était pas d'accord avec le fait
de sortir un texte
maintenant voilà nous on a pris texte
comme il était et on a vraiment essayé
de l'enrichir autant que faire se peut
et il me semble quand on parle du
service public de l'emploi quand on
parle des mesures qu'a évoqué françois
tête et surtout surtout parce que plutôt
que de décider pour les collectivités
pour nous ce qui est important c'est de
leur permettre de la faculté d'avoir
cette liberté conventionnelle et de
délégués aux droits déléguer des
compétences entre elles voilà ce qui
n'existait pas c'est en tout cas n'était
pas sécurisé endroit donc pour moi il me
semble quand même que les apports du
sénat ils sont pas neutres
en tout cas ils respectent aussi une
autre volonté qui est oui d'aller vers
la déconcentration mais de le faire en
concertation avec
avec les collectivités et nous on a dit
tout de suite qu'on n'était pas pour un
grand soir non plus les élus attendent
aussi à ce que on avance pas à pas donc
voilà on voulait pas révolutionner mais
compléter utilement c'était complément
de ce que dit monsieur vous qui
connaissez bien le sujet moi je vous
invite à relire peut-être le texte que
nous avons fait parce que nous tirons
les enseignements des lois territoriale
précédente où on est venu de manière
autoritaire imposé à chacun de faire la
même chose
or vous avez vu que nous on a gonflé le
volet de différenciation c'est à dire
permettre aux collectivités de prendre
des compétences qui leur allait bien et
d'en déléguer au triste c'est quand même
une révolution
donc nous on donne de la liberté pour
s'organiser de manière la plus adaptée
deuxièmement on a une audace qui est
folle alan mais il faut vous en rendez
compte sert quand je vous dit tout à
l'heure que nous nous demandons le
transfert de la médecine scolaire au
département nous demandons que les
gestionnaires de cantines des
départements et des régions soient
transférés à ces collectivités que nous
demandons que les directeurs
d'établissement de petite enfance et
leurs adjoints soient transférés nous
nous le poussons maintenant c'est le
gouvernement qui au banc à la réponse à
la question passe comme l'a dit mathieu
darnaud nous de la seule autorité du
législateur nous ne pouvons pas faire ça
il faut que le gouvernement lève le gage
alors de l'audace on en a plus qu à
revendre quand elle est juste et
pertinent et donc nous nous poussons la
question au gouvernement et si le
gouvernement s'oppose à ces transferts
qui sont des transferts de cohérence et
d'utilité c'est-à-dire pour faire ce que
la loi vous oblige après vous ai besoin
de gérer votre personnel si le
gouvernement dit non à ça sincèrement il
ya des grandes leçons silencieuse à
thiers tous à temps
mais cela a été dit j'ai un peu de l'art
dit c'est qu'il y avait une volonté des
élus locaux de trouver une période de
stabilité
il faut l'entendre ça c'est la première
fois la deuxième chose nous sommes
saisis d'un texte du gouvernement qui
par les règles parlementaires elle-même
nous bloque notamment sur toutes les
mesures qui ont des conséquences
financières
donc on a pas de liberté de manoeuvre
aussi grande qu'on veut bien le laisser
entendre
et puis le troisième point c'est qu'on a
eues ici trois propositions de loi
constitutionnelle qui ont été voter ici
qui n'ont jamais été qui aiment bouger
fondamentalement les choses qui n'ont
jamais été reprise par le gouvernement
non plus mais on aurait aimé qu'elle le
soit donc le contexte mais il boutabout
fait qu'effectivement nous travaillons
voilà comme les commissions ici
travaillent sur des mesures très
concrètes
à périmètre constant si je puis dire
donner ses expressions permettre
institutionnels constant pardon pour
être parfaitement précis pardon est
imposé bien sûr bien d'écouter je vois
qu'il ya pas de questions
supplémentaires nous reste à vous
remercier de votre présence et je vous
livre les rapporteurs si vous voulez
d'après-midi à toutes et à tous
[Musique]